Did Qatar "buy" fans?
Did Russia threaten to "ban" the World Cup
in Qatar?
And will a match at this World Cup not last
90 minutes but 100?
All these rumors are actually circulating
on the net about the FIFA World Cup in Qatar.
And even more.
But not everything is actually true.
We have checked that for you.
But first, a few facts about the biggest sporting
event of the year:
This is the first ever World Cup to be held
in the Middle East.
It is the first World Cup to be held in winter.
Qatar is the smallest host country in World
Cup history.
The World Cup in Qatar is by far the most
expensive tournament ever.
But will the tournament be played all the
way to the final?
Social media users sowed doubt about that:
after Russia was banned by FIFA for attacking
Ukraine, President Vladimir Putin reportedly
threatened, "Russia will play at the Qatar
2022 FIFA world cup or there will be no world
cup to talk about."
As this this viral Facebook post suggests.
False
There is no proof that Putin said that and
no media has reported about it.
Even on the Kremlin website, where all Putin's
speeches are documented, there is no mention
of it.
Fact is that only FIFA can cancel or stop
the World Cup, not Russia.
This poster also caused uproar.
It was shared on the web in dozens of languages.
It allegedly shows rules for the World Cup,
such as that alcohol and homosexuality are
forbidden in Qatar.
Misleading
Contrary to what many people thought, the
poster does not come from the Qatari government.
The Qatari citizens' initiative "Reflect Your
Respect," which has been calling on foreigners
in particular to respect Qatari customs since
2014, is apparently responsible for the poster.
And what about the content of the poster?
The Supreme Committee responsible for the
World Cup said it showed "factually incorrect
information."
So, which of the bans are true?
Let's take a closer look.
With regard to alcohol consumption, the law
in Qatar is clear: Alcohol is not prohibited,
but drinking it in public is.
This is punishable by up to six months in
prison.
Dating, however, is not forbidden under Qatari
law.
And homosexuality?
That is a punishable offense in Qatar.
Qatari law punishes it with one to five years
in prison.
Homosexuality and the World Cup in Qatar - a
topic that provides for discussions as seen
after a recent statement by the Qatari World
Cup ambassador.
And the debate of homosexuality and the World
Cup in Qatar lead to fakes like this one:
Here Cristiano Ronaldo and Lionel Messi are
allegedly kissing.
And Qatar is calling for the two to be banned
from the World Cup, according to this Facebook
post, which has been shared thousands of times.
Both are fake, of course.
It is a photomontage, meant as satire, with
which a youth format on Swiss television in
2021 wanted to draw attention to the treatment
of homosexuality in football.
And Qatar's demand that Messi and Ronaldo
be excluded from the World Cup is completely
made up.
The same goes for this story: FIFA is said
to have excluded Algeria's fans from the World
Cup, as is claimed on Facebook and Youtube.
They are not allowed to travel to Qatar.
False
Algeria did not qualify for the World Cup.
However, fans from Algeria were not excluded.
We could not find any such rules or entry
requirements, neither from FIFA nor from Qatar.
Speaking of fans.
This news made international headlines: Qatar
is said to have "bought" fans.
That's right, at least in part.
Qatar has invited selected international football
fans and paid for their flights, hotels, accommodation
and even given some pocket money.
The Dutch broadcaster NOS was the first to
report on it.
And we have spoken with fans who received
this offer.
SOT Joseph Delage, Fan aus Frankreich: "The
offer included the air ticket, the hotel costs
and a ticket for the opening match.
But you had to stay for the entire first round.
The idea was also that you can participate
in cultural and sports activities."
"Plus: We are given a per diem for meals.
After that we are on our own to buy our match
tickets.
We are on our own to enjoy the tournament
as it is.
That’s everything in a nutshell."
The Supreme Committee responsible for the
World Cup confirmed to us on request: flights,
hotels and accommodation costs are paid for
selected fans.
Nevertheless, they were not "bought", according
to Qatar.
Because no consideration in the sense of "promotion"
was expected, reports about it are "absolutely
false."
But is that true?
In our research, we come across an official
paper that speaks a different language.
In the "code of conduct," Qatar expects participating
fans to do exactly that: promote.
Fans are supposed to agree to support the
Qatar World Cup "by liking and sharing" social
media posts, using the hashtag #IAMAFAN and
tagging the official Roadto2022 channel.
Qatar also advises participating fans that
their posts will be "monitored."
Qatar could require fans to delete posts that
violate the Code of Conduct.
And "disparaging the World Cup OR Qatar" is
not appropriate.
According to our information, the Code of
Conduct was not presented to all fans.
But for the fans who were sent the document,
it's fair to say that Qatar indirectly paid
them with flights, hotels, tickets, and pocket
money - in exchange for social media reach.
And in this case, Qatar is said to have paid
fans as well, as social media users claim.
During fan marches in Qatar, thousands walked
through Doha wearing jerseys of the participating
nations.
According to our information, most of them
are migrant workers, many from India.
Qatar has offered them heavily discounted
tickets to World Cup matches.
And it is not the first time that Qatar has
been accused of employing migrant workers
as sport fans.
Qatar is also fighting back against these
headlines: International media accuse the
kingdom of restricting press freedom.
This is because camera teams have to sign
a list of conditions and bans that massively
restrict their work.
Qatar's Supreme Committee contradicts via
Twitter: Filming is allowed after obtaining
permits.
And journalists can "report freely and without
interference" in Qatar.
False
According to our research, truly free reporting
from Qatar without state interference is not
possible.
Government buildings, religious institutions,
universities, hospitals, homes and private
businesses may not be filmed without permission.
This is also confirmed by the International
Federation of Journalists (IFJ).
These restrictions would prevent the media
from reporting on topics of public interest,
such as human rights violations.
We know that Doha News has been suspended
for a long time as well for their reporting.
We know that The New York Times was not able
to make its stories available on certain specific
issues, such as LGBTQIA+.
"Secondly, we are also concerned about a law
that exists in Qatar which makes any spreading
of fake news or rumors subject to very heavy
fines and up to five, five years jail term."
Particularly interesting: Qatar's government
controls who reports when and how about the
guest workers in the country - their poor
working conditions have been a controversial
topic for years.
Journalists are therefore hindered and censored
in their work in Qatar - a circumstance that
many observe with great concern.
But there are some bizarre rumors about the
upcoming FIFA World Cup.
Like this fake that made us laugh.
Here, a Facebook user claims that during this
tournament of the World Cup a match would
last 100 minutes instead of 90.
Really?!
Of course, this is false.
A football match lasts 90 minutes, and that's
how it will stay in this World Cup as well.
And FIFA has also confirmed: there will be
no changes in the match length.
Some things will be different during this
World Cup.
But some things will remain the same.
Have you come across more World Cup fakes?
Then write to us: in the comment section below
or to factchecking@dw.com